باي باي بيردي بهذه الكلمات الساخره
انتقدت نائبه رئيس المفوضيه الاوروبيه
للقيم والشفافيه فيرا فيرا جروبا حراره
منصه تويتر بالانسحاب من قانون مكافحه
التضليل في الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن اين قامت
بالانتقاد
على تويتر القانون الذي تتحدث عنه النائبه
وقعت عليه منصات عده متى جوجل تويتر
ومايكروسوفت وبموجبه ستكون هذه الشركات
ملتزمه بدءا من الخامس والعشرين من اغسطس
المقبل بمواجهه المعلومات المضلله لكن ما
معنى ذلك هل يستطيع تويتر الان التخلص من
التزاماته بعد قرار الانسحاب
وفوضع الصناعه الاوروبيه تالي بريتون اجاب
لا وشبه الامر بانه يمكن الربط ولكن لا
يمكن الاختباء حتى على تويتر
[موسيقى]
اطلقت اوروبا هذا القانون من اجل الحد من
المعلومات والبيانات المضلله المعلومات
والبيانات مهمه اهم حتى من النص لانها
مورد متجدد بوصف
نائبه الرئيس التنفيذي للمفوضيه الاوروبيه
والمسؤوله عن اوروبا ملائمه للعصر الرقمي
ولذلك اطلقت اوروبا قانون مكافحه التظليل
الذي انسحب منه موقع تويتر فما هي تبعات
هذا الانسحاب قد يتم حظر المنصه في اوروبا
ربما رساله ضمنيه لبقيه الموقعين على
الميثاق اكثر من 16 مليون متابعا لتويتر
في فرنسا قد يحرمون من استخدام حساباتهم
على المنصه المثيره للجدل فاعتبارا من
الخامس والعشرين من اغسطس من العام الجاري
سيحضر تويتر في اوروبا ولن يغرد في فرنسا
مره اخرى بعد هذا التاريخ في حال لم يلتزم
بقواعد الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا القرار ياتي
على خلفيه اعلان المنصه الانسحاب من مدونه
الاتحاد الاوروبي للممارسات السليمه وضد
تضليل الاعلامي عبر الانترنت لكن رغبه
اداره تويتر في التملص بشكل رئيسيا من
واجبها في ازاله المحتوى غير القانوني
وحظر الاعلان الذي يستهدف القاصرين قد
يعرضها لدفع غرامات ماليه تصل الى سته في
المئه من حجم الاعمال لتؤدي في نهايه
المطاف الى اختفاء المنصه في الفضاء
الاوروبي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات